so with you know McConnell paralyzed or
whatever having a stroke or whatever it
is having everyone agrees something bad
happened but do you want to be the one
person in the room to go what what did
Biden just say and they're gonna go did
you not hear him I'm not here do your
job for you also people that don't speak
English but some some will but there's
got to be of the 95 of liberal
journalists don't they don't you think
someone's guy's been closed doors going
yes or can we not see the sign language
interpreter is like why doesn't one come
out of their closet it's well no no it's
because what happens is these these uh
corporate journalists after Biden gives
a speech and they take notes they walk
into the back room say I have no idea
what he just said so you tell me and
then they they look over at their CIA
Handler who then says here's the quote
and then they just type whatever
whatever they're told by the Intel
agencies there you go that's that's
there you go what is like the sign
language interpreter they have sign
language interpreters of that events
were they just standing there like what
did he say no like I just went like this
that's the University